Prof: Something that I
will be charting as we move
through the episodes that make
up Part II is how they are
reminiscent of others in Part I;
how, in many cases,
these episodes in Part II are
rewritings of episodes in Part
I.
This is an issue that doesn't
have to be just stated,
but also pondered.
I mean, what does that mean?
Does it make a statement about
there not being a possibility of
something new and original,
of memory impinging on the
present so strongly that you
cannot really move away from it,
and so forth?
So when I discuss these
episodes I will try to link them
to episodes in Part I,
and I hope that you do the same
as you read,
because the book invites you to
do so from the very beginning,
when Sansón Carrasco
sort of takes over as the
internal author of Part II,
and you realize that what
Sansón Carrasco wants Don
Quixote to do is to reenact Part
I,
to be like he was in Part I and
to do the things that he did in
Part I.
And, in fact,
many of the characters in Part
II that Don Quixote and Sancho
meet want them to act like as
they did in Part I.
So this is something that can
be seen as sort of an
overarching topic about in my
discussions of Part II,
and that I hope that you will
also do as you read and think
about Part II.
We are going to begin today
where we left off in the last
class,
talking about that
all-important term that I was
discussing,
called desengaño.
Desengaño is
perhaps the most important
concept of the Spanish Baroque.
Remember, Baroque is
essentially seventeenth century
spilling over into the
eighteenth century where it
becomes Rococo,
if you want to be more precise.
So desengaño is
perhaps the most important
concept of the Spanish Baroque;
it means undeceiving,
opening ones eyes to reality,
awakening to the truth;
these are all valid
translations of the term.
Engaño,
in Spanish, means 'deceit,' to
be fooled;
'te engaño' means 'I
fool you';
'engañarse' is 'to fool
one self.'
This concept is fundamental to
Part II because the whole plot
of the novel seems to be moving
towards disillusionment.
So let me give you some
definitions of
desengaño and
comment on them so that we can
have as clear a concept,
as clear an idea of this
concept as possible.
The first is from Otis Green
and his book Spain and the
Western Tradition.
Otis Green was a great
Hispanist at the University of
Pennsylvania for many years,
through the '40s,
'50s, and even '60s,
and his book is a treasure of
information about Spanish
literature and culture of the
Golden Age.
He writes: "This
desengaño is
related to the sort of awakening
to the nature of reality that
the prodigal son must have
experienced,
'I will arise and go to my
father,' says the prodigal son.
This waking to true awareness
is called 'caer en la
cuenta' [in Spanish;
it's another way...]
'caer en la cuenta' to
have the scales fall from one's
eyes, to see things as they are.
Such a state of mind is
desirable."
I continue with Green:
"Disillusionment comes to
be viewed even to be venerated
as a sort of wisdom,
the wisdom of the stoic sapiens
or wise man of antiquity who was
fully aware of what constituted
the summum bonum,
the supreme good,
and was utterly un-enticed by
everything else."
Unquote.
You know who were the stoics
were, so this wise stoic man
knew what the real good was and
what was not valuable:
"Caer en la cuenta
[I go on with another quote from
Green],
to come to one's self was the
phrase most used in connection
with the type of
desengaño we are
considering here.
It signified a passing from
ignorance to knowledge,
and awakening from the falsity
of one's dream."
Unquote.
So you can see now this
dialectic, as it were,
between engaño
and desengaño,
deceit and un-deceit,
deceit and disillusionment,
and coming to realize what is
the truth.
The following is the quote that
I gave you at the end of the
last class.
It was on the back of that map
with the Don Quixote's route on
the way to Saragossa,
and then the swerve to
Barcelona, and it's the
following,
and it is from Baltasar
Gracián.
Baltasar Gracián was a
Jesuit who wrote about politics,
wit and rhetoric.
He lived between 1601 and 1658
and he wrote a very famous
allegorical novel.
An allegorical novel is a novel
in which the characters
represent abstractions:
reason,
truth, and so forth,
and the novel is called El
Criticón,
The Big Critic.
Here is a quote from that book,
it's the quote that you have,
it's a quote about
desengaño:
"The most monstrous of all
is the placing of Deceit at the
world's front gate and
disillusionment at the exit--
a disastrous handicap
sufficient to ruin our life
entirely since ...
to make a misstep at the
beginning of life causes one to
lurch headlong with greater
speed each day and end up in
utter perdition.
Who made such an arrangement,
who ordained it?
Now I am more convinced than
ever that all is upside down in
this world.
Disillusionment should stand at
the world's entrance and should
place himself immediately at the
shoulder of the neophyte,
to free him from the dangers
that lie in wait for him.
But since the newcomer--by an
opposite and contrary
arrangement makes his first
encounter with deceit [who at
the beginning presents
everything to him in perverted
and reversed order]
he heads for the left hand road
and strives on to
destruction."
As you can see,
this is very allegorical the
left hand road;
the left is always the bad,
sinister.
'Sinistra' it means
left, this is why it has that
connotation.
The left road is the bad road,
and so you have deceit and
disillusionment,
and he says,
is placing deceit--if this is
the door to life,
deceit is here,
and then the end of life is the
other D,
Disillusionment;
this is what he saying.
Gracián was allegorical
in his mode of thinking.
Deceits are all of Don
Quixote's illusions,
and those of the other
characters in the novel.
While desengaño
is what they wind up or what
they reach, disillusionment,
realizing that it is all vanity
of vanities.
This is the reason why so much
of what happens in Part II is
staged.
Deceit is the theatricality of
so many events which are made
up, constructed;
deceit is the dream of books
that Don Quixote dreams,
it is the unbroken chain of
texts masked in reality,
and even of language also
masking reality.
So Don Quixote's dream of
books, these illusions about the
romances of chivalry and the
knights of old is a deceit,
and disillusionment,
is coming to realize that it is
that,
that it is nothing but a
deceit, and the unbroken chain
of texts is because in Don
Quixote's mind one text leads to
another,
leads to another,
leads to another.
It's a humanist dream,
the humanists,
who were philologists,
lovers of language,
students of the classics,
thought in terms of texts
leading to texts,
without ever getting to
reality,
and of language of something
that has its own reality,
and what the baroque does is
undermine all of that and show
that it is all a dream.
The best example of these
patterns of deceit and
disillusionment,
or of going from deceit to
disillusionment is the play by
Calderón de la Barca,
Life is a Dream.
I have put his name before on
the board,
but I will do it again so that
you remember him,
he's one of the classics of
Spanish literature--
You can't see from there?
Pedro Calderón de la
Barca.
I am very fond of Pedro
Calderón de la Barca and
of his play,
Life is a Dream,
because I wrote my entire
doctoral dissertation about that
play,
and it is one of the classics
of Spanish literature.
In that play,
Life is a Dream,
in English, prince Segismundo
has been kept in a tower since
birth because an omen told his
father,
king Basilio,
that Segismundo would be a
ruthless tyrant if he ever
became king,
so he has him grow up,
since he's a baby,
in a tower, cared for by
Clotaldo and so forth.
To put him to a test,
Basilio has Segismundo drugged
and brought to the palace,
where, when he awakens,
he is treated like a king.
Confused, Segismundo acts
violently,
he tries to rape a woman,
throws a soldier off a balcony,
and so forth,
confirming the omen,
in a way,
so he is drugged and brought
back to the tower where,
upon awakening,
he does not know if what
happened in the palace was true
or just a dream.
Meanwhile, the people who have
found out about Segismundo's
existence,
the people in the kingdom,
revolt and come to get him to
fight against his father.
Segismundo hesitates because he
does not know if this is another
dream,
but decides to go with them and
act prudently and justly,
this time, because he realizes
that even in dreams it is best
to do the good,
because if life is like a
dream, the only true life is the
life after death.
He dethrones his father,
but does not kill him;
and marries the woman he should
marry, not the one he had lusted
after during his first day in
the palace--he controls his
desires.
The message is that life may
very well be like a dream in a
platonic sense,
but even so one must behave
morally.
As you can see,
the plot of the play,
which I have simplified,
goes from deceit,
the first visit to the palace,
to disillusionment,
when Segismundo awakens back in
the tower,
and wisdom, when he comes to
know that life is like a dream,
as are political power,
the trappings of government,
and everything else.
The only thing that,
by the way, that he knows was
true when he awakens in the
tower is his love for this
woman,
the only continuity is the
emotion of love,
and that is a neo-platonic
element in the play.
It's a more complicated play
than I have just made it seem
here.
We will have occasion--we will
see a very similar story when
Sancho becomes a ruler later in
the Quixote.
My suggestion here is that the
plot of the Quixote as a
whole follows a similar outline
from deceit to disillusionment,
from engaño to
desengaño.
We will have,
of course, occasion to revisit
this when we come to the end of
the novel,
but keep it in mind also,
keep all of this in mind,
also, when you read for next
week the wonderful story,
The Glass Graduate,
El licenciado vidriera,
which you are to read for next
week--
next week we have a big week,
we have The Glass
Graduate,
and also we are going to be
doing two of the main essays in
the Casebook, the
ones by Spitzer and by Auerbach,
about whom I spoke in the last
class already,
so you should be prepared to
read that essay of "The
Enchanted Dulcinea,"
an episode that we are going to
be discussing here today.
This is so we can keep our
course not going from deceit to
disillusionment,
but to be wide-eyed about
everything from the very
beginning.
So let us begin today as we
move to the episodes in the
Quixote about the discussion
of Don Quixote and Sancho about
knight-errants and saints that
I'm sure you remember.
First, there is the exordium by
Cide Hamete Benengeli and
comments by the narrator about
what the translator said,
or what the narrator said about
Cide Hamete Benengeli,
but the reader does not know
where these comments appeared--
and we talked about that in the
last class.
They are not in the text,
as it were,
but in a sort of meta-text or
virtual text that is like a
running commentary about the
composition of the novel,
and this is one new feature in
Part II that I mentioned before.
Now, Sancho subjects Don
Quixote to a rigorous cross
examination and gets him to say
that saints are better than
knights--I'm sure you remember
that.
Sancho has rhetorical skills,
as does Sansón,
who earlier had used forensic
rhetoric to ease Don Quixote's
sally.
Sansón may have acquired
those skills in Salamanca,
but where did Sancho learn them
or anything else,
where did Sancho learn rhetoric
or all of this culture that he
has in his mind?
I think that the intimation is
that Sancho has learned a great
deal not just from Don Quixote,
which he does,
and we have seen,
but also from hearing sermons
at church,
which he mentions in his
discussion with his wife.
The church is on this level
part of popular culture,
or better, a vehicle for the
popularization of culture.
Sancho may not know how to
read, but he has a culture in
his head that he has absorbed
from the preachers.
This is one way to explain the
evolution of Sancho and his
increased intellectual and
rhetorical powers,
although, of course,
his relationship with Don
Quixote,
as I will mention in a couple
of minutes,
is obviously the most important.
The discussion per se,
the theme,
the topic of the discussion is
very serious here,
too, because it plays into
religious debates of the time in
Spain,
whose background is the
Reformation.
The debates have to do with
good works and with
predestination and free will,
Protestantism sided with
predestination,
Catholicism,
or at least one element within
the most important one,
for free will.
So therefore,
if you had free will,
you could, through good
actions, gain access to heaven.
Now, these are debates that to
us,
in this our secular age seem
vacuous,
but they were not in the
sixteenth century at all,
they were of the utmost
important.
So here, in this discussion,
it is not just a question of
arms versus letters,
which is a set discussion
piece, although there is a
reminiscence of that here,
but of good actions for their
own sake,
and good actions for the sake
of glory.
Sancho shows that the knight's
actions seem to be of this
second kind,
actions to gain glory,
and this feeds into the topic
of desengaño and
engaño.
So to perform actions for the
sake of glory is to perform
actions for the sake of deceit,
of engaño.
Don Quixote counters by saying
that there were knights who were
saints.
I suppose that he refers to
Saint George particularly,
and adds that not everyone can
be a monk, he says.
Cervantes is,
I think, pitting his
relativistic and liberal take on
life,
which is not antireligious,
against the religious zealots
of the time,
I think, through this
discussion of his characters.
So the discussion has a
contemporary relevancy that is
political as well as religious,
and this is connected to what I
said in one of my earlier
lectures about the fact that
Part II is the first political
novel,
because religion and politics
were intertwined in the Spain of
the sixteenth and seventeenth
century,
with all of the caveats that we
have learned by reading Elliott.
So this discussion of the two
characters about this issue is
consonant with the political
side of Part II.
I want to underline that,
so that you have that clear in
your mind.
Now, Sancho also demonstrates,
as he has before,
and as he will increasingly,
that he is endowed with natural
reason,
which can lead him to
understand sufficiently the most
difficult questions.
Natural reason is a medieval
concept that survives through
the Renaissance and reaches the
Enlightenment,
which underscores God's gift of
sufficient reason to every
individual no matter what his
station in life to understand
the fundamental questions,
issues of life.
This will become an important
topic in Part II;
natural reason,
and Sancho will be the exemplar
of this.
It is a theological concept.
Now, one can see,
of course, that because Sancho
has been influenced by Don
Quixote,
their arguments are like
discussions the knight could be
having within himself,
or with himself.
What is the significance of
their mutual influence?
I think that to propose a
concept of the self as
relational, not as individual or
isolated.
Not "I think,
therefore I am"--
I'm quoting Descartes,
of course, which comes a little
later--
not so much "I think,
therefore I am";
as "I relate to others and
myself emerges from that
commerce or dialogue with
others."
This is what the Quixote
through this relationship
between these two characters
seems to be suggesting.
Now, of course,
this is a very profound
philosophical statement,
a suggestion,
but it also crucial in the
development of modern fiction.
Think of Huck and Jim,
in Huckleberry Finn of their
dialogues and of their influence
on each other,
think of Holmes and
Dr. Watson,
to give you an example from
popular culture,
and even of those Faulknerian
characters that seem to overlap
and blended to each other,
to the point that you sometimes
don't know who's really speaking
in one of these Faulkner novels,
you don't because his
characters consciousness are
sort of blended,
and their individuality has
been eroded.
This is what I'm suggesting is
happening here in Don Quixote
and Sancho, and why this
argument is one that Don Quixote
could have had within himself.
Now, this discussion also
brings up Don Quixote's
knowledge of classical Rome and
its architecture.
Rome is the city par
excellence in the
Renaissance, and its
architecture was the model for
Renaissance architects.
This shows--remember that
Cervantes spent quite a bit of
time in Italy,
so when he speaks of Rome,
he's speaking not only of
things he has read about in
books,
but also things that he has
seen.
Now, this shows that Don
Quixote is a humanist,
that he has read beyond the
romances of chivalry.
In Part II, we are beginning to
enlarge Don Quixote's library,
we cannot reduce it to the
romances of chivalry that we
found with the barber and priest
in the scrutiny of the books,
but he had read other things.
It also anticipates Part II's
projection beyond Spain.
I say beyond Spain because as
Don Quixote and Sancho go to
Barcelona they are moving to a
part of Spain that is almost not
Spain.
Cataluña,
being, even today,
a part of Spain that is very
independent in its culture and
has,
in fact, tried to become
independent several times,
and also, of course,
the battles that you will see
at the end of the book beyond
the shores of Barcelona,
move beyond the borders of
Spain, so this projection
towards Italy is important in
that respect.
But also this discussion points
out that architecture is an
important issue in Part II.
It's an important issue
because, as I have mentioned
before, a great deal of Part II
takes place indoors;
in houses, in mansions and so
forth.
In Part II, we have less,
although there are some,
of those two places that I
mentioned in Part I:
the despoblado,
the unpopulated--Remember that
that is even a legal concept,
that area where the law does
not reach--
and the other one that I didn't
put on the board,
but you must have seen the word
many times,
these are the soledades.
Soledades are when you
are out in the wild.
There's less of this in Part II
and more of shelter,
more of architecture,
and this is why the discussion
on roman architecture is
important,
above all, in the context of
humanism,
and the Renaissance,
and the copying of Rome's
architecture and the,
of course, the development of
what will become Baroque
architecture,
and that scheme that I gave you
about Beinecke Plaza,
Sterling Memorial;
you blend them,
force them together and you get
the Baroque.
Now, this emphasis on cities
brings us to the entry into El
Toboso.
The third sally takes place at
night,
and a day goes by,
and then, at night they enter
the town,
the village of El Toboso,
and being at night,
this anticipates much of the
mood of Part II.
Remember, Part I began at dawn.
Don Quixote and Sancho want to
arrive in the town at night so
as not to be noticed,
and that night is called in the
Spanish una noche
entreclara,
"a night that was not
quite a dark one"
says Jarvis,
and this, I underlined because
of the concept of
chiaroscuro that I
mentioned before,
the concept of
chiaroscuro as something
proper to the Baroque.
"Una noche
entreclara."
There is darkness,
sounds, dogs barking,
donkeys braying,
swine grunting,
cats meowing,
a plough being dragged,
there is an eeriness to this
town augmented by these sounds.
The farmhand they meet is
singing a song about a great
defeat which adds to the omens,
the bad omens.
Sounds, as opposed to visual
signs, appear before them.
In Part I we had the fulling
hammers, but in Part II there
will be many more sounds,
as you will see.
These sounds here are scary by
virtue of the fact that you
cannot see their source,
you can only hear.
Seeing is going to be a
different problem in Part II
because of the increasing
darkness.
This is the first time that Don
Quixote and Sancho come into a
town and it anticipates the
entry into Barcelona,
a city, a great city,
towards the end of the novel.
What is the significance of
this?
I have mentioned this,
the novel, which develops from
the Quixote,
will be for the most part an
urban genre,
a genre often about cities,
modern cities,
and Don Quixote's influence on
the history of the novel
includes this urban part of
the Quixote,
particularly as you will see
when you get to the Barcelona
chapters.
Here, El Toboso appears as a
haunted city with blind allies
and peopled by strangers,
the farmhand,
who do not know anything about
it.
The farmhand is an outsider who
cannot give them directions.
I have always been puzzled and
sort of even scared by this
farmhand in the middle of night
who doesn't even know where he
is,
and I think I know why,
and if you will allow me a
little anecdote:
I was lost in the Pennsylvania
turnpike at night once,
trying to find a town
improbably called Indiana,
Pennsylvania,
where I was giving a lecture.
I got off the turnpike and I
was lost, in little towns,
in Pennsylvania,
they were dark with little
lights.
I drove my rented car towards
the sidewalk,
because I saw a man coming,
I lowered the window and I
said,
"Could you tell me how to
get to the turnpike,"
and he went,
"I'm deaf. I'm deaf."
I said, "Oh God,
he's deaf,
he can't help me,"
I raised the window,
and I followed,
and I found a little gas
station with one little light
bulb,
and I got out of the car,
and this guy came out with only
one eye,
he had a hole on the other side;
I said, this guy can't help me,
and so I was lost for hours,
they were about to send for the
National Guard,
I finally found Indiana of
Pennsylvania,
where I was lodged in a Holiday
Inn with a Mexican motif,
and I was given the Taco Room.
So this is my anecdote,
and this is what brings to mind
this farmhand who appears in the
middle of the night and can't be
of any help because he doesn't
know anything;
he's not from there.
So there are deep resonances,
to me,
of Spanish mysticism in this
dark, night of the soul to echo
Saint John of the Cross,
the great Spanish mystic poet;
it's the name of one of his
great poems, "Noche oscura
del alma."
It recalls seeing the depths of
the soul in the darkness of
night.
Sancho is actually looking for
a memory that is a lie,
the story he made up about
going to El Toboso remembering
something that he knows does not
exist,
he's trying to remember
something that he knows does not
exist,
it's a made up memory,
and Don Quixote is looking for
a non-existent lady who is the
object of his devotion:
both protagonists are searching
for intangibles in the dark of
night,
as if it were,
within their troubled spirits,
and this is the,
I think, the impression,
that this El Toboso at night
conveys.
Right away we come upon a line
that has inspired much useless
commentary;
when looking for Dulcinea they
run into the church.
The line in Spanish reads:
"Con la iglesia hemos
dado,
Sancho,"
Jarvis translates:
"We are come to the
church, Sancho."
Modern readers have seen in
that sentence a hidden meaning,
that is, that Cervantes is
decrying the interference of the
church in all affairs,
and the line has even become a
standard phrase in Spanish to
say that you have come against
some obstacle:
"con la iglesia hemos
dado,
Sancho,"
when you come against some
obstacle,
particularly when you are
denied something or other.
I think that is only because of
the rhythm of the way the
sentence is written,
not "hemos dado con la
iglesia, Sancho"
but "con la iglesia
hemos dado,
Sancho,"
but it doesn't have anything to
do with that,
this is why I mean that it is
useless,
but it has remained in the
Spanish language as a ready made
phrase.
I think that what is
significant here is that
Dulcinea's castle has morphed
into the church,
that in looking in the dark for
Dulcinea's castle they have
found a church,
or the church,
in the gloom,
where things are difficult to
identify,
Sancho is scared because he
knows that the cemeteries are
around churches,
and he doesn't want to be in a
cemetery at night.
This could be a telling
transformation,
perhaps an indication that Don
Quixote's love is a kind of
religion,
or more likely,
given what will happen over and
again in Part II is an
intimation of death of which
there are many in this eerie
chapter.
This ghostly night in El
Toboso, the first adventure in
Part II, sets the tone for the
rest of the novel.
So now we move to the chapter,
we're not going to go through
every single chapter,
as I've mentioned before,
but here we move to a very
important chapter,
the one on the enchanted
Dulcinea.
It's important not only because
it inspired Auerbach's famous
essay of "The Enchanted
Dulcinea"
that you will be reading,
but also it is a chapter that
will play an important role
later,
in one of the most important
episodes of Part II,
one of the whole
Quixote,
the episode of the cave of
Montesinos,
where this enchanted Dulcinea
will come back.
So, first of all,
it is one episode in which we
notice, once again,
but very dramatically,
an exchange of roles between
Don Quixote and Sancho.
The first time was when Sancho
played the role of Don Quixote
to his wife,
who was playing his own role in
that hilarious dialogue that
they had,
but here the exchange of roles
is much more dramatic.
The first thing to notice is
Sancho's Shakespearean monologue
that dramatizes his inner
conflicts and reveals his
apprehensions about Don Quixote.
He doesn't know quite what to
do;
Sancho is here like a rustic
Hamlet: "to be or not to
be."
He weighs the various options
that he has, and he opts for
trying to fool Don Quixote with
the trick of turning this
peasant woman into Dulcinea.
Sancho is becoming a fuller
character and increasingly
important to the novel.
He is one of the pranksters who
fool Don Quixote.
He will be, in this sense,
like Sansón Carrasco and
like the Duke's steward who will
appear later.
Also, Sancho is separated from
his master here as when he went
to deliver the letter in Part I,
but this prefigures several
important episodes in Part II in
which they are separated,
and Sancho plays the role of
the protagonist of his own part.
But the most important thing
about this Shakespearean
monologue,
as I call it,
is that we are exposed here to
Sancho's inner world,
his world of doubts.
Then, of course,
there is inversion of roles:
Sancho is the one trying to
convince his master that what
they see is not really a
reality,
but something drawn from the
chivalric romances,
and he does a pretty good
imitation of Don Quixote's own
rhetoric in trying to convince
him that this wench is Dulcinea.
So reality, which Don Quixote
perceives as it is,
conspires spontaneously or
arranged by someone to appear as
unreal, literary,
artificial.
Hence, the episode depends on
the memory of Part I and of
similar episodes.
Here, I think,
that the episode in the
background is that of the
windmills;
it's that inversion.
It is here Don Quixote who
says: what giants?
Where is Dulcinea?
What do you mean, Dulcinea?
That is the episode in the
background here.
Now, the peasant lass reacts to
Sancho's rhetoric a little bit
like the prostitutes in the
first inn when they react to Don
Quixote,
though the prostitutes in the
first inn were kinder to Don
Quixote than these peasant women
here,
who are very upset because they
think that upper class young man
or men are making fun of them.
This is really a truly
hilarious episode,
one that makes me laugh,
as I said the last time,
every time I reread it,
particularly the part about
Dulcinea smelling of garlic,
which I will mention again.
But there is also the issue of
Dulcinea's bodily hair,
specifically in Don Quixote's
interpretation Dulcinea's pubic
hair.
If we go to page 530,531,
Sancho is talking and he says:
"...by which we might have
guessed at what was hid beneath
that coarse disguise [he's
talking about her body]:
though,
to say the truth,
to me she did not appear in the
least deformed,
but rather all beauty,
and that increased too by a
mole she had on her right lip,
like a whisker,
with seven or eight hairs on
it,
like threads of gold,
and above a span long [long
hairs].
'As to that mole' [this is the
pedantic answer by Don Quixote]
'according to the
correspondence there is between
the moles of the face and those
of the body Dulcinea should have
another on the brawn of her
thigh [the inner part of her
thigh],
on the same side with that on
her face,
but hairs of the length you
mentioned are somewhat of the
longest for moles.'
'Yes I can assure your
worship,' answered Sancho,
'that there they were,
and looked as if they had been
born with her.'
'I believe it,
friend,' said Don Quixote,
'for nature has placed nothing
about Dulcinea but what is
finished and perfect;
and therefore,
had she a hundred moles,
like those you speak of,
in her they would not be moles,
but moons and resplendent
stars.'"
The description is remindful,
of course, of Maritornes,
but there is something specific
about a hairy Dulcinea.
Bodily hair,
a lot of hair,
was taken then as an indication
of a heightened sexuality,
of a strong sexual drive.
This and other hints,
there will be other hints,
and there have been others--you
can look them up in my book,
Love and the Law in
Cervantes--
of bodily hair on Dulcinea and
other women,
moustaches and so forth.
Look for them now,
as you read the book and
believe me, they are there,
I haven't invented them.
These and other hints reveal a
story behind the story here that
I have hinted at before.
What lurks beneath Don
Quixote's courtly love style for
Dulcinea is the sexual desire of
an aristocrat for a peasant lass
presumed to be of ardent
sexuality,
who promises to provide more
pleasure than the women of his
class.
There is a literary tradition
behind this that reaches back to
the Spanish ballads,
but that is also quite alive in
Cervantes' time.
At least two of Don Juan's
conquests--
you know who Don Juan is the
figure of Don Juan,
the womanizer and so forth,
who first appeared in Tirso de
Molina's play.
I have mentioned the fact that
the Don Juan figure is one of
the figures created in the
Spanish Golden age by Tirso de
Molina,
I better put his name on, too.
He is the inventor of the Don
Juan figure,
a great legacy then,
in literature and music and so
forth--
At least two of Don Juan's
conquests in Tirso de Molina's
play,
The Trickster of Seville
are from the lower classes,
one a peasant and the other a
fisher woman.
The Dulcinea in this scene also
underscores her physical prowess
by the way she mounts her
donkey,
by taking a little run back to
get some momentum,
and leaping on it from behind
and riding it astride,
like a man.
It's a very sexual and vulgar
gesture that she makes that I
find absolutely hilarious,
and then when Sancho says,
"my God,
she's quite a horseman,
she could teach a Cordovan or a
Mexican to ride a horse,
the way she leaps on it,"
and she just goes on.
Also by her smell of raw
garlic, which Jarvis translates
as 'undigested garlic,' which
reveals her coarseness,
and also her proximity to food:
food and sex go together.
Now, I know,
that, of course,
garlic doesn't sound very sexy
to anybody anymore or ever
perhaps, but this is the
intimation.
The whole transformation of
Dulcinea will leave a deep
imprint in the knight's
subconscious,
as we shall see in the episode
of Montesinos' cave.
But now Don Quixote and Sancho
are about to meet theater on the
road,
this road that in Part II
appears to be full,
not of real characters,
as of characters and objects
playing roles or disguised as
something else other than what
they are.
So they meet now,
the cart of the parliament of
death,
which is a cart carrying actors
who have finished putting on a
play in one town and go to
another nearby to repeat the
performance,
hence, they have not changed
out of their costumes.
The play that they stage is a
kind that you have already met
before, though very briefly,
in the Grisóstomo and
Marcela episode.
If you remember that episode,
Grisóstomo was said to
write the autos
sacramentales.
These are the religious plays
performed on the day of Corpus
Christi,
the feast in honor of the
Eucharist or communion
celebrated on a Thursday on the
sixtieth day after Easter.
Therefore, it's coherent with
the chronology of the novel,
it's taking place in summer so
Corpus Christi,
communion, the Eucharist,
is celebrated in this feast
every year,
and part of the feast was the
performance of this place,
which always deal with the
topic of the Eucharist,
the mystery of the Eucharist,
the transformation of Christ's
body into blood,
and into wine and bread.
They usually have plots drawn
from scripture,
but also plots drawn from
classical mythology.
These autos were a
medieval retention in every
sense,
and now think about what I said
about the Baroque going back to
the Middle Ages,
jumping over,
back over the Renaissance,
this is a medieval retention,
the auto sacramental.
They were one-act plays
performed on carts,
precisely.
They are carrying themselves on
the cart and they are also
carrying,
with the cart,
the stage, because the way that
these autos were performed were,
if you have a town square,
let's say the church is here,
the other buildings and so
forth, the carts were put,
one--if there were two or
three--one for each scene,
and then the people would be
here, and the performance took
place on the carts,
and elaborate props and scenery
were created on the carts,
because these plays represented
cosmic events of the world,
I mean the universe,
the stars, and so forth,
would appear,
and then when the play was
finished--
this was a very modest play
with only one cart--
the cart would move on to the
next town.
So they were carrying with them
their stage, not only
themselves, but also their
stage.
They were simple enough so that
all of the people could
understand them,
but sophisticated in
versification,
imagery and theological
content.
Calderón de la Barca was
the most famous author of
autos sacramentales,
but many other poets and
playwrights wrote them,
including Lope de Vega,
who was the author of the one
mentioned in this episode,
Las cortes de la Muerte,
which is a real one-act play by
Lope de Vega translated here as
The Courts or Parliament of
Death.
In the play,
Man, with a capital M--
remember it is an allegorical
play--
is subjected to a trial after
having been tempted by the
devil--
this is where the devil appears
here.
Another figure is that of
Madness, represented by the
actor who spooks Rocinante with
his bells and bladders.
Remember, this one who comes
after they have had their
dialogue,
and he has a stick with--they
didn't have balloons because,
of course, there was no plastic
to make them,
so they made these balloons out
of the bladders of slain
animals,
so bladders and bells,
and he plays Madness.
The most famous of these autos
was one by Calderón
called The Great Theater of
the World,
whose theme was that of the
world as a stage where man
performs life,
as if it were a play,
before going on to the real
life after death at the end of
the play.
The one performed by these
players in this episode of
the Quixote,
who, by the way,
were a real company of actors
of the time,
is very much along the lines of
The Great Theater of the
World, but the conceit here
is that of a trial for man.
So this is what it is in the
background of this scene.
So theatricality is an
important element in Part II
because of what I mentioned,
theatricality is part of the
deceit that would lead to
desengaño,
but it's also--you will also
find it at the inn,
where Ginés de Pasamonte
appears as a puppet master.
Death, who appears here as part
of the ensemble of actors--
because Death was an
allegorical figure that appeared
in this--
is also important in Part II,
and it is a medieval retention,
so is the devil.
Everyone here is in costume,
including, of course,
Don Quixote.
Reality is all ready play,
illusion;
there is no need for Don
Quixote to misinterpret it.
But notice the subtlety that
the plays then assume their
roles in reality.
The Madness begins to play
Madness in the reality of Don
Quixote.
The devil plays a trick on
Sancho, and the presence of
death,
even in allegorical dress is
frightening,
and reality is buried beneath a
layer of various forms of
representation.
A man dressed as a literary
character meets men and women
dressed as literary characters.
The devil who steals Sancho's
donkey parodies Don Quixote and
his fall from Rocinante.
Here is a madman facing an
actor playing the role of
madness, as if reality were
offering Don Quixote a mirror of
his own deranged self.
This is something that will
happen over and again in Part
II,
and we will find another
example very soon,
when Don Quixote meets the
Knight of the Mirrors.
Life is play acting,
as Don Quixote says,
using a word that you are now
familiar with.
He says: "Y ahora digo
que es menester tocar las
apariencias con la mano para dar
lugar al
desengaño."
That's what is says in the
original.
And Jarvis does reasonably well.
He says: "And I say now
that it is absolutely necessary
[says Don Quixote]
if one would be undeceived
[desengaño]
to lay one hands upon
appearances [to see that they
are appearances]."
Cervantes, by the way,
is punning here,
because in the Spanish of the
seventeenth century
'apariencias' also meant
'stage props.'
When Calderón wrote the
instructions for the carpenters
to make the stage he called
those "Memoria de
apariencias,"
apariencias were stage props.
So by this pun Cervantes is
underlining the theatrical
quality of this episode and of
the quote unquote
"reality."
Two things important to remark
and remember for this scene is
that Don Quixote meets an image
of his madness,
something that will happen
throughout Part II,
and it is kind of a point of
madness,
where madness reflects madness,
nadness for us,
as readers, too.
And also, we must remember the
presence of death,
which is a warning against the
deceits offered by life.
Death devalues all of the
allures of life with its
presence, and we have met it
before in El Toboso when they
bump against the church.
Finally, the loop of the story
here,
of this little story,
of this episode goes from
deceit to disillusionment,
from engaño to
desengaño.
If Micomicona and the process
by which her story was concocted
was like a representation of
representation,
the episode of the cart of the
parliament of death is
representation in motion,
or actually representation even
on wheels, one could say.
I want to close by reading you
a little vignette that I wrote,
as an epilogue to this episode.
I've told you that professors
and critics can hardly resist
the temptation of crossing the
line and becoming writers,
and this is my very modest
falling into that trap.
It goes like this,
it's very brief and very silly
now as I reread it,
but I think that it will give
you a laugh:
"Satisfied,
after recovering Sancho's
donkey from the wild devil who
had stolen it in jest to mock
Don Quixote our pair got back on
the road on their journey to
Saragossa.
They had not traveled very much
when they saw in the distance a
cloud of dust,
picked up by what seemed like a
large contingent of horsemen,
only that from afar their
mounts looked enormous,
fit more for giants than for
men.
They brought Rocinante and the
donkey to a halt,
shaded their eyes with their
hands and peered into the
approaching murky mass,
unable to discern what it
contained.
As when he first saw the cart
with the players,
Don Quixote was brimming with
anticipation.
This had the makings of a
superb adventure fit for his new
stature, as a knight whose
exploits had already been the
object of a book.
As the strange contingent drew
nearer,
Don Quixote and Sancho were
astonished to discover that it
consisted of a brightly dressed
man in Moorish dress sitting
atop a huge camel and covered by
a green canopy.
He was comfortably positioned
on a lavish saddle with his legs
crossed, on which he cradled a
device that our heroes could not
see.
Behind him rode in a splendid
dromedary a younger man dressed
as a morisco.
He too was covered by a
parasol, yellow in his case,
and was in a similar position
and cradling something in a
fashion similar to the man on
the front,
who was obviously his master.
They were surrounded by a troop
of men on horses,
well, armed and carrying
banners.
Both parties stopped and gazed
at each other in wonder.
Don Quixote was the first to
speak: 'My dear sir,
would you please state your
name, nation and mission?
as I suspect by your garb and
weapons that it could not be a
good one, in which case,
I must challenge you to single
combat.'
The gentleman,
somewhat plump and placid in
appearance did not look up from
the device on which he seemed to
be tapping with both hands.
At length, he lifted his head
and answered the knight in an
incomprehensible gibberish that
the man behind on the dromedary
interpreted nearly at once as
follows: 'My dear Don Quixote de
la Mancha,
I am Cide Hamete Benengeli,
author of your story and your
creator,
and the man behind me is my
translator who is transcribing
in Spanish what I write here in
this laptop in Arabic.'
He said this without stopping
his typing, for had he done so,
the whole scene would have
vanished without a trace.
Don Quixote and Sancho were
speechless and motionless,
and the tapping ceased.
Silence fell over the baron
Castilian landscape;
the novel had finally and truly
come to an end."
Well, I have here a few notes
from your exams,
of things that I found very
interesting.
It's not everyone,
so don't be jealous if you're
not mentioned,
you'll be mentioned in the next
one.
But Tony wrote about the lack
of introspection in the
Quixote,
and that is true,
but this will change in Part
II,
and he also said that
"those who like the
romances of chivalry are also
like Don Quixote,
and in a way,
that is extends to us."
That was very good.
Kelsey, "being an author
and the danger of insanity"
she writes,
which is true:
being an author,
as you can see with my little
attempt here,
carries the danger of insanity.
And Sancho, she says "is
fat and short and therefore
closer to the ground,"
I found that to be very
interesting.
Tara, "Don Quixote doubles
Cervantes,
both are readers and authors of
chivalric romances,"
it is true, so I found that to
be...
Jasmmyn, this is in Spanish,
"doubles who are
interlaced to complete,
as it were, the character of
Don Quixote."
That was very good,
I thought.
Ariel found various frames in
Las Meninas,
it's true, the frame of the
picture,
the frame in the picture,
the frame of the door,
there is repetition of frames.
I found that to be a very,
very interesting insight.
Elizabeth, "Cardenio makes
Don Quixote more believable as a
character since someone else
exists who is like him."
Toby, "in turning Don
Quixote's world into a world of
dialogue he and Sancho both
changes it and preserves."
So this is your own feedback
that I found very interesting.
So I'll see you in the next
class or this Friday,
I will be there,
should you want to come see me.
A few of you have already come
and we have had very pleasant
conversations,
and I am eager to receive you.